♪
>>> WELCOME BACK TO "CBS THIS
MORNING."
THERE IS NEW FALLOUT FROM A
DISTURBING VIDEO SHOWING THE
VIOLENT ARREST OF AN OLDER WOMAN
WITH DEMENTIA.
OFFICERS CONFRONTED KAREN GARNER
AS SHE TRIED TO WALK HOME IN
LOVELAND, COLORADO.
YOU CAN SEE HER BEING SHOVED TO
THE GROUND.
THREE OFFICERS HAVE NOW RESIGNED
AFTER GARNER'S FAMILY FIRED A
FEDERAL LAWSUIT.
AND NOW THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY IS
LOOKING INTO POSSIBLE CRIMINAL
CHARGES.
OUR LEAD CORRESPONDENT DAVID B
G
BEGNAUD IS FOLLOWING THIS.
THE FAMILY SAYS THIS ALL STARTED
WITH A MISUNDERSTANDING.
>> Reporter: INDEED, MISS KAREN
GARNER HAS DEMENTIA, WENT TO
WALMART.
ON THIS PARTICULAR DATE, SHE
PICKED UP A PEPSI, KIT-KAT AND
WIPES AND TOOK IT WITHOUT
PAYING.
SHE BROUGHT IT BACK.
NEXT THING YOU KNOW THERE'S MISS
KAREN WALKING DOWN THE ROAD
HERSELF WHEN A LOVELA POLICE
OFFICER DRIVES UP.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS NEXT.
>> THIS IS MOM'S JACKET THAT SHE
HAD ON THE DAY IT HAPPENED.
AND IT'S GOT THE MARK ON THE
BACK WHERE HER HANDS WERE
HANDCUFFS.
>> Reporter: THIS IS ALLISA
SWARTZ TALKING ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED TO HER MOTHER.
GARNER TURNS.
SHE KIND OF SHRUGS.
>> DO YOU NEED TO BE ARRESTED
RIGHT NOW?
NO, NO, NO, LET'S STOP.
COME ON.
>> Reporter: SECONDS LATER SHE
IS FACE DOWN IN THE DIRT.
HER ARMS ARE HANDCUFFED BEHIND
HER BACK.
THIS 73-YEAR-OLD LADY IS
PLEADING WITH THE OFFICER TO LET
HER GO.
HER HOME IS JUST TWO BLOCKS
AWAY.
>> ON THE GROUND.
A STRUGGLE, SHE'S NOW TAMED.
>> Reporter: OFFICER HOFF
REFUSES HE PICKS GARNER UP AND
PUSHES HER TO HIS SQUAD CAR.
>> RIGHT NOW, YOU'RE RESISTING,
WHICH IS NOT GOING TO FLY WITH
ME.
IF YOU TRY TO KICK ME SHE'S
CRYING OUT.
>> Reporter: A ANOTHER OFFICER
DARIA JALALI COMES AROUND.
AND THAT'S WHEN YOU HEAR A POP.
MISS GARNER COLLAPSES IN PAIN.
>> I'M GOING HOME, SHE KEEPS
REPEATING.
THIS IS AN 80 POUND WOMAN WITH
DEMENTIA.
SHE WAS ACCUSED OF STEALING
$13.88 WORTH OF ITEMS FROM THE
NEARBY WALMART.
STORE SECURITY CAUGHT HER AND
SHE RETURNED THE ITEMS.
BUT DESPITE THAT, THE POLICE
OFFICERS WANTED TO ARREST HER.
>> SHE WAS SO SCARED.
SHE DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS
GOING ON.
>> Reporter: I WATCHED THE VIDEO
AND I THOUGHT TO MYSELF, HOW DID
HE NOT REALIZE, SHE JUST KEPT
SAYING I'M GOING HOME.
MAYBE THERE'S SOMETHING ELSE AT
PLAY HERE.
>> RIGHT.
>> Reporter: MAYBE IT'S NOT THE
NORMAL SITUATION.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I HAD
THOUGHT, TOO.
I WAS LIKE, DID HE NOT
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE SHE'S
REPEATING OVER AND OVER.
I'M JUST GOING HOME.
>> Reporter: RIGHT.
>> AS IF HE WASN'T LISTENING TO
HER.
>> Reporter: AT THIS POINT,
GARNER'S TAKEN TO THE LOCAL
JAIL.
>> THEY HURT MY WRIST.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT.
>> Reporter: HERE SHE IS SITTING
IN HER CELL REPEATEDLY BEGS THE
OFFICERS TO HELP HER.
>> THEY HURT MY SHOULDERS.
THEY HURT MY SHOULDERS.
>> Reporter: ACCORDING TO COURT
PAPERS MISS GARNER SAT THERE
MORE THAN SIX HOURS WITH NO
MEDICAL ATTENTION.
AS IT TURNED OUT SHE HAD
SUFFERED A DISLOCATED SHOULDER,
FRACTURED ARM AND SPRAINED WRIST
ALONG WITH SCRAPES AND BRUISES
OS HER BODY.
BACK AT THE STATION, THE
OFFICERS MOCKED HER.
GARNER'S FAMILY HIRED A SOUND
ENGINEER TO ENHANCE THE AUDIO.
LISTEN.
WHAT HAS THAT INCIDENT DONE TO
YOUR MOM'S CONDITION?
>> IT'S ACCELERATED IT.
SHE'S SCARED.
SHE'S ANXIOUS.
>> Reporter: LAST MONTH, MISS
GARNER'S FAMILY FILED A FEDERAL
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE CITY OF
LOVELAND AND FIVE POLICE
OFFICERS FOR VIOLATING KAREN
GARNER'S CIVIL RIGHTS.
THEY CLAIM THAT OFFICER HOPP
USED EXCESSIVE FORCE AND THIS
GARNER WAS LEFT WITHOUT
NECESSARY MEDICAL ATTORNEY.
THE LOVELAND THOSE LEFT WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS, LAW ENFORCEMENT
SHOULD ATTEMPT TO ESTABLISH A
SINCERE RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
INDIVIDUAL.
>> YOU KNOW, IT'S SICKENING.
>> Reporter: AND THAT'S THE
MAYOR JACKIE MARSH.
>> THERE OBVIOUSLY NEEDS TO BE
ONGOING ANALYSIS OF WHERE PEOPLE
ARE IN ATTITUDE.
>> Reporter: DO YOU THINK THEY
NEED TO BE PROSECUTED?
>> I THINK THEY NEED TO GO TO
JAIL, YES.
THEY NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Reporter: WE TRIED TO REACH
THE OFFICERS AND THE ATTORNEYS,
BUT WE COULD NOT.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT THE
FAMILY ATTORNEY TOLD US THAT
RIGHT AFTER THE INCIDENT LAST
JUNE, THE D.A. GOT A CHANCE TO
LOOK AT THE VIDEO AND WHAT HE
SAW LED HIM TO DROP THE CRIMINAL
CHARGES AGAINST MISS KAREN.
BUT NOTHING HAPPENED TO THE
OFFICERS THEN.
NEARLY A YEAR PASSES.
AND IT WASN'T UNTIL THE FAMILY
ATTORNEY RELEASED THE VIDEO
PUBLICLY THAT THE THREE OFFICERS
RESIGNED.
AND NOW ANOTHER ONE IS ON
ADMINISTRATIVE LEAVE.
TONY I CALLED THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY LAST NIGHT AND ASKED
HIM WHEN THERE MAY BE A
RESOLUTION IN THIS CASE.
HE SAID BY THE END OF THIS WEEK,
HE COULD HAVE AN ANNOUNCEMENT AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT HE'